I time for today's bar shot how high can
Chinese stocks go if you listen to mark
mobius who of course is the executive
chairman of Templeton Emerging Markets
Group he's been investing in emerging
markets for the best part of four
decades he says the bull market in
Chinese stocks is just getting started
and it was Mobius his words that
inspired today's bar chart check out the
chart this is the benchmark the shanghai
composite in 2014 and this year it's
risen by thirty-nine percent the most
since two thousand a night in the last
month alone in the last month alone the
index has gained nineteen percent the
Chinese central bank unexpectedly cut
interest rates mainland investors
opening new stock accounts at the
fastest pace in five years only
Venezuela's benchmark stock index has
risen more in the last month out of 93
global indices now the high for the year
was reached on Monday have a look here
where my pencil is pointing my my pennis
pointing that was when the indexer past
3,000 for the first time in three years
the index finished on monday at three
thousand and twenty that's the highest
since april 2011 now what's interesting
is this and this is the stat that really
matters the indexes 51% jump from a
four-year low in june 2013 is still less
than half the average 122 percent gain
during 26 bull markets since 1990s if
you're a believer in history this market
could have further to go be aware of
volatility there on the gauge on tuesday
the shanghai composite index that fall
right there it fell by 5% biggest
one-day tumble since 2009 China stepping
up efforts to curb the expansion of
opaque local government debt also a
measure of ten-day prices swings reached
the highest level since 2009 on
Wednesday don't let that put you off
those says mobius he
as increased volatility is creating
opportunities to buy mispriced shares he
isn't alone in heralding chinese stocks
morgan stanley's jonathan garner said on
december the second there's potential
for an ultra bull rally where prices
double in 18 months there are naysayers
though ken Peng he's a strategist at
City group's private bank in Hong Kong
he says the rally is irrational and very
quickly and eg a former world bank
economists he called the but he called
the advance a bubble driven by leveraged
traders I'll let you decide